you
why don't we start a jade you want to
start each of you give a little brief
intro overview of your journey and
entrepreneurship and then we'll launch
into these very pressing and we've oh I
yes please follow cell phones need to be
off we're taping this so the cellphones
interfere with the transmission so if
you can please turn your phones off that
would be hugely helpful so thank I have
an answer here to keep me honest Jay you
want to start jaiprakash graduate from
the GSP last year in June and so my
journey to entrepreneurship I started
prior to the gist be I spent a few years
in consulting in sports than a couple
years in private equity and so I came to
the GSB thinking I want to do something
more entrepreneurial and I used my
summer between my first and second year
to work yet I started called bonobos
which was started by some GSP of sevens
you guys have probably seen emails about
it by now really enjoy that came back my
second year deciding i wanted to
something that was very entrepreneurial
and focusing consumer products spent a
lot of time meeting with different
companies thinking about different ideas
on my own and ended up at a company
called rebloom which right now I'm the
CLO I was employee number two the
product launched in May and we sell it
two and a half pounds natural sleep
drink that's an alternative to things
like ambien town elf gamma night bill
and so I started in July and been there
for nine months come on and so my name
is Elon astern I am the founder and CEO
of weddington way which is an online
boutique for bridesmaid dresses it's
basically a social shopping for bridal
parties um I was a buyer for
bloomingdales prior to the GSB and came
in sort of knowing that I was passionate
about the fashion industry and
fascinated by a lot of the
inefficiencies in the industry but not
sure yet what I wanted to do about it um
basically started working on the idea
for weddington way summer between my
first and second year a lot of actually
time spent with EJ we shared an office
of bonobos for a couple weeks during the
summer
I actually did it something different
than a J which is spent part of the
summer in consulting and part of the
summer at bonobos half my time at the
nobis was spent doing a project for them
and half of it was spent doing a project
for myself and basically just got going
in the second year with weddington way
took advantage of the you know time at
the GSB to do a massive amount of
consumer research was was really the
most important thing for us to
understand where the pain was coming
from with brides in the process and
incorporated weddington way in may of my
second year got our first commitments
from investors the week of graduation
and started a cult i'm really the day
after graduation so my name is Alex
al-azhar GSB 09 my company is called
katha soft and we were making
application security software so we're
trying to make application security easy
and our projects based on an open source
project that we also have called Apache
Shiro so we're very much in the
enterprise software space my background
prior to the GSP was in enterprise sales
for IBM so I've always lived in
enterprise software while the GSB I was
very busy I ran the club along with Dana
who's not here right now and I also put
together the e conference and it was a
great time my summer interest was in
venture capital also folks enterprise
software and then I spent my second year
fleshing out a thesis around cloud
software try to start a company based
off that that company that I'm not
working out and in a few months later
and applying this opportunity started
this company the different partner which
took about nine months after I graduated
the first prescribed question we have is
what about what you didn't take
advantage of while at the business
school but these three students alums I
think we're particularly good about
taking advantage of many things at the
business school so in addition to
talking about what you wish you taken
advantage of how much you guys in
particular to talk about what you did
take advantage of because they were
really full time residents in the CES so
well the other way Alex yeah you talked
about it a little bit so uh so I took
advantage of everyone
my hands on the CES was was ground zero
I spent I spent I think at least twice
two days a week just at the CES not just
eating we're not just eating with Linda
with Nancy and just using that as kind
of my headquarters for all the work I
was doing I also really leverage the
network that the school has I mean when
you're a student you have access to
everyone anyone and everyone will take
your call anyone and everyone will give
you time anyone and everyone will tell
you information they shouldn't give you
and so I took advantage of that and
build a fantastic network people that
really really helped and some of which i
financed our company so and I'm also
participated in everything
entrepreneurship club had which also
gave me a very strong network of fellow
classmates and alums who are also
entrepreneurs which has been probably
one of the most important things in the
first year and just helping to stay sane
is having people around you are in the
same book so anything that you think you
missed yes so the flip side to that
equation was that I had no spare time
while i was in school and that actually
from an entrepreneurship 10 point was
difficult because i didn't have a lot of
free time to really evaluate ideas in in
the capacity that i should have been
evaluating them all knowledge in school
and then have the opportunity to really
just spend time working on concepts and
testing them Wallace student I had to
actually wait until I graduated and then
had spare time to go do that work in
hindsight it we're not working lights
with the working one um so I think we're
probably all going to echo each other to
a certain perspective but um essentially
for me I think the most beneficial thing
was really getting out there talking to
alums talking to people connected with
community investors other entrepreneurs
and just getting a lot of feedback on
the idea as it was evolving and there
was sort of nothing more beneficial from
just a testing the idea perspective from
the building confidence perspective
learning how to talk to other
entrepreneurs learning how to talk to
investors and really sort of getting the
hang of how everything works we all want
can you talk about how you either did or
did not do that in the context of class
as well yeah so okay so you
that's a good point so I would say what
I wish I had done more of actually is
taking more entrepreneurial classes
earlier um we had when I was their first
year was a little bit less flexible in
terms of extra classes we could take
beyond the core um but what I did get a
massive amount out of so I took 356 in
my second year and we developed a lot of
what weddington way is through the 356
class that was huge and just getting
other students involved in the idea
seeing like learning how to excite a
team having to pitch every other week it
was just incredibly valuable formation
of new ventures mge I took mg with joel
peterson another phenomenal class and
just a lot of the classes where it's
just you know sort of throw away the
cases and really dig into a real
business idea dude role-playing where
you're really sort of stepping outside
your comfort zone I think you know a lot
of entrepreneurship is doing things you
don't know how to do every single day um
and you have to a lot of the
entrepreneurial classes really helped me
sort of step outside of my comfort zone
and keep pushing myself to the next
level so that I really sort of became
conditioned and got totally used to it
so what did you miss her what do you
wish you had done yeah so I mean it just
I think getting sort of i think the
biggest thing i did you is there was so
much benefit and reaching out to the
alumni network in my second year and
just the network around stanford and i
wish i had done more of not in my first
year so i guess this is a little bit
more relevant for first years just start
finding excuses to reach out to alums
you know as early as you can and just
start figuring out how to engage people
in conversation it's really beneficial
really on okay yeah so things i did they
were good i think start talking my
classes the three classes I took that
are probably the most valuable for me
right now our mg who I took what grows
back I think you just when I ticket I
thought it was like okay when I'm
running a company 10 years from now I'll
use these things but the lessons you
learn they
come up in everyday conversation with
vendors with hiring whatever and so it's
been super valuable touchy feely is an
amazing class so I think everyone to try
and take it if you're a first year and
yet you still the chance to sign up and
then 356 I took which was just the start
of plastic so I didn't have an idea that
i have i wanted to i knew i wanted to
consumer products and so I work with
another guy on a sneaker idea just you
know was able to use that to leverage
how I think about selling how I think
about customer is how I who I'd reach
out to and the GSP networking outside of
that the only thing I really did was my
second year I started a speaker series
through the CES which is called the
consumer products founder series and it
was probably more selfish than anything
because I knew I want to be consumer
products and I just use it to reach out
to as many people from the GSB who
started cool companies and I brought a
man I think we're bringing like 10 or 11
speakers and over over a few months so
that was a really useful thing for me
I'm still in touch with a handful of
them and they've been in you know live
in advisors for me things that you know
I don't really have any regrets from the
juicy I think I did a lot of things I've
wanted to do you know it's one of those
unique times where you can kind of learn
whatever you want to learn and focus
your time whatever you want to if I did
any two things differently one would be
potentially just putting a stake in the
ground earlier of what I wanted to do I
kind of came back I came first year at
the GSB not sure if I was gonna start up
go back to private equity go back to
sports you know do whatever but then
second year I started realizing I wanted
to be a consumer products and so I
started from the stake in the ground it
was much easier to have conversations
with the lungs with fellow classmates
whatever in terms of just saying this is
where I want to go and the other thing
which is nothing to do with startups
rating is like I wish I would have just
played more tennis play more basketball
how I got more because the second you
get out of the second inning is startup
there's so much to do and so little time
for anything else so take advantage of
being here and I think Jay had a great
point that I mean it's kind of joking
when he started the consumer product
speaker series selfishly but and it
doesn't just hold at the GSB it holds I
think in general in the population if
you do something to kind of serve what
your personal desires and these are
you're going to serve a broader
population as well and it gives you an
excuse to reach out to people and build
those deep relationships which become a
great foundation for other things as
well so and it doesn't just hold here at
the business school
I think it holds in life in general so
what about your biggest lessons that
you've learned up to this point Ilana
you're in the middle Europe I would say
you know they're there are a lot of
different ways I could answer that
because I learn lessons every day um but
you know some of the takeaways I have so
far number one follow your gut for me
you know in everything I do you know
there's a point at which you just can't
rationalize a decision anymore and you
just have to sort of let your instinct
guide you in terms of you know whether
it's forming your team or building
relationships with like suppliers or
partners you know just stuff I do every
day it's it's really important to follow
my gut because ultimately we're moving
pretty quickly and I sort of have to you
know just make sure I continue to push
the business forward um another thing
that has been incredibly important is
transparency and this goes back to a
Jays point with touchy-feely a lot of
what I learned in touchy-feely I do use
everyday learning you know just being
really open and honest and communicative
with everyone that I work with and just
really laying it out on the table has
been absolutely paramount to just sort
of building a strong team and
accomplishing what we need to accomplish
so it's a those are sort of the two
things that drive me every day I agree
with that said I sort of thought about
this and there are four things that I
think are key lessons I've learned one
is my situation potentially little
different than than these two in the
sense that there was a founder who had
developed a product over a year and a
half and then was bringing me on as his
first hire but in the sense if you
thinking about doing a start-up with a
co-founder or whatever one thing I was
told before going into entrepreneurship
was that it's like a marriage and I kind
of didn't I don't really believe that
but the reality is is John the founder
of reading 5 spends more time with me
that his wife probably and we get lunch
every day together when they all
together every day together and so one
of the biggest lessons I learned is that
underlying values are critical like as
long as you guys you know we see the
same way in terms of how we want to do
business how we want to build the
company that's really important and
we're in the process of recruiting right
now we're bringing on a third employee
today actually and hopefully a fourth
one of the next month and like as we've
gone through the process of meeting a
lot of people it's been very critical
for us to decide whether that person
fits our values and wants to grow the
business and the way we do and there's a
lot of situations where your values are
tested so I think that's one that's the
biggest lesson I've taken oi second is
that startups are super volatile so you
better be ready for ups and downs every
day I mean the way I like to say it is
its ups and downs but always moving
forward I mean there's a punch in the
stomach every day for some random reason
and you just got to be able to handle it
and move forward and realize that you
know if you have a product you like or a
company that you believe in that you're
going to move forward and figure out the
right with it to get things done another
thing is that you know if you're doing a
start-up you should try and find a way
to have balance in it I mean you're
taking a giant pay cut and you're taking
the ability to to control your schedule
so realize that nothing's really bad
urgent and you know you should be able
to find a balance enjoying enjoying what
you're doing feeling happy and content
but also having a balanced with
non-starter for like things and then it
was already alluded to but the fourth
thing was just that the GSP network is
incredible I actually I came in to
rebloom right when we were about to
launch a fundraising process and I will
tell you that any any GS BLM i emailed
whether they were at a seed Condor
institutional fund individual angel
whatever every single one of them
replied to me and even though as you
don't want to take a meeting at nothing
to consumer products were responsive and
helpful and if we look at the people
that eventually invested I'd say I mean
the large majority that hard GSP alarms
or types would just be so high and so I
think the network is as amazing as so
you should keep in mind so curve for me
the biggest lesson I've learned over the
first year is that customer feedback or
feedback from the outside world is as
tricky it's like dynomite
and you can't create a company without
it you can't create a good product
without it but if you use it the wrong
way you'll blow your hands off so part
of the part of that lesson was being
really clear on what feedback you
actually want from the people you meet
with because everyone will give you
feedback and and so an example of that
is never ask someone what they think of
your product don't ask them that
question the question that matters is
will they buy it and if they buy how
will they use it because if you ask them
what they think about it they may tell
you all the things that are wrong with
it all the things that they think are
awesome about it and none of those may
have any impact and one or not they buy
it and so somebody may tell you because
they're trying to be helpful that you
know oh here are all the critiques I
have for your product and they really
are doing from a good place and you come
out of that meeting thinking your
product sucks they don't want it but
then if you ask that same person would
you buy it based on what it currently is
they might say yes and you need to know
that and so we just once we figure that
out we just stop asking people what they
thought the product just kept the
question two will you buy it the other
thing is you can be careful who you ask
for feedback from so the benefit of the
GSB is that you have an amazing network
to talk to that's really tricky because
you might go meet with someone who is
extraordinarily powerful and you go meet
with them and you get their feedback on
your product and that person tells you
that doesn't make any sense they don't
think it's going to have a good market
they don't see how it's going to go to
market it's going to be too expensive
integration is going to be an issue but
when you actually say that I can think
about it they're not your customer
they've never been in your space they've
never done anything related to what
you're starting and so the feedback
ended up being completely useless or
vice versa they may tell you it's
completely awesome but all those things
still hold so you get a false negative
or false positive so when you meet with
people you'd be really clear on what
they what their feedback actually should
matter to you so if it's someone who's
really important ask him a question that
they know and have credibility in so if
they've been a vp of sales at some big
company and ask them a question
I go to market don't ask them about if
you're probably going to sell because
they're not going to know if they're you
know if it's mark zuckerberg you know
don't ask him if you liked your product
asking how you would integrate to his
sales platform or something like that so
those things were very hard lesson but
now that we've learned them our feedback
sessions and our customer meetings that
have come a lot more give a little
little bit Alex to something as you
thought was important that wasn't but
we'll start at the other hand is there
anything that you thought was
particularly important that ended up not
being you being so i thought was
particular part of that isn't my worded
question whatever you prepared for okay
i I don't know I'm it's hard to say
because I think I'm still learning every
day and you know for me to tell you that
some class I took wasn't important next
week it might become super clickable so
I for for right now I mean I think it's
one of those things where I'm moving
forward eyes wide open always a learning
I'm finding that certain classes have
become very important have become
applicable certain things like I mention
mg a touchy feely are sort of everyday
things but we've had to deal with
negotiations we're taking negotiations
was helpful and I'm I have no doubt that
some of the accounting stuff is I mean
what about even things in your business
I mean did you think raising money at a
particular time was particularly
important or getting a particular
customer um I mean raising money was
important I think for us we've we've
tried to stay pretty balanced with how
we approach things and you know don't
let Phil know things affect us too much
so fundraising you know we got it done
in december we'd like to get done in
october november but it didn't help hold
us back it started as long as long as
you have cash in the bank and you feel
like you can move forward nothing really
stopping us and so we've had delays and
issues but i don't think there's
anything that's that's a surprise that's
too much I think you guys put too much
weight on then I think I don't know I
know um sort of I would say you know
through like through the GSB and just
through sort of training and everything
like font and finance when you start a
business there can be a
didn't see to sort of want to model
everything out to the last detail and
make sure that you haven't missed
anything um two things I would say is
you know understand your market
opportunity sort of understand your
business model or what you think it's
going to be and you know you do want to
make sure it's viable but then move on
because you could sort of spend all day
in Excel trying to make you know every
assumption perfect and the only way you
can make an assumption perfect is to
start running the business and have real
date at a plug-in model is i would say
sort of one thing that was i don't know
that i've seen i guess a lot of people
sort of get caught up on and i would say
make sure make sure not to for me
everything i learned in the first or
strategy class it just it just isn't
important your first year strategy like
the best laid plans you can think about
competitive at competitive advantage and
barriers to entry and supplier power and
buyer power and none of it matters
because it's all going to change
dramatically me for talking to customers
and it's going to change every week
until you actually hone in on what your
visit model really is going to be and
what end up well i think what we came to
was it you don't define that all that
stuff that you learn strategy you know
you're evaluating these multi-billion
dollar companies in your you're
analyzing their strategy but you don't
get to pick that really i mean there's a
really small parts you get the pic but a
lot of us really reflection of the
market you're in it's a reflection of
the space you're in a new technology
you've built what what what i would say
was most important in in terms of
strategy is make sure you're in a big
market and make sure you're in a market
that's growing and if you're in those
things and you a product people actually
want to buy because you're solving a
real problem everything else it doesn't
matter in the first year doesn't matter
in the first years it'll matter if you
become really big but in the first few
years only thing matters is a big market
you have a growing market and you have a
product you will want to buy so would
have been some big inflection point
for you in your businesses and we were
debating on what that means before the
candle started an inflection um so I
think the first one for me was in
November of my second year I basically
had a pitched weddington way the first
time in a September session class and
just started propelling forward into
sort of working on the idea in november
i cold-called a bunch of brands in new
york and basically said i'm the founder
of this like amazing company and i'm
going to be in New York will they meet
with me um they somehow agreed got off
the phone with these like seven brands
like in one day and booked a ticket to
New York and the next week went to New
York and and met with all these brands
and got them to agree to sell to my
non-existent company with a non-existent
website so um that was really though is
step one and that was really big because
when our first customers inflection
point number two came to me and April
saying basically they heard that I was
working on something with bridesmaid
dresses can I help them I was able to
say yes because i actually had product
to sell to them even though i didn't
have a website yet um i would say number
three was probably they knew who's over
there weddington ways director of
merchandising agreeing to join this
crazy venture turning one to two so i
was able to tell my investors that our
team size had doubled which was really
exciting and you know then you know we
launched the beta of our website in
november and from there it's just it's
been moving at a mill
miles an hour whether it's testing our
first facebook ads and realizing they're
awesome for us which is really exciting
or launching our first contest which we
did on Monday with a wedding planning
site it's just sort of you know i guess
i would say that what is an inflection
point that you know one of the piece of
advice have been given by a lot of
different people is celebrate small
victories at a start-up because i have a
lot of ups and downs so you can have
inflection points every day I mean I
with rebloom something some of the
sudden I can or interesting would be
prior to when I started but I now
they're a couple of collection points
when John was developing the product and
they're up there a million but a couple
of point I was you know he had raised a
friends and family around so he had some
money in the bank and ended up agonizing
over the decision to buy the URL rebloom
calm and spent five thousand dollars one
of those things were in hindsight thank
God we did because it just makes a ton
more sense growing the business and in
other things we spent about a third of
his entire friends and family around on
hiring a world-class packaging design
company for the bottle and getting that
all set up and that was one thing I know
he spent a ton of time debating but you
know 1feedback 1 piece of feedback we've
gotten from investors and potential
advisors all that sort of stuff is that
you know the packaging looks great and
if you want to in consumer product
specifically if you want to sell the
premium product only need definitely
that looks good and it can look like
something its type targeted to mass
appeal inflection point since I've
joined I mean the product launched about
a month before I joined and I would say
that you know there's been a bunch of
stages in terms of since I've started I
mean the big thing for me when I came in
his fundraising so obviously you know
that was my major focus coming in and
once we close around that was a big
inflection point because we were talking
about well we have X amount in the bank
what are we going to do what we're gonna
do then all of a sudden we had a lot
more in the bank and it was like okay
now we can actually think about building
this company the next inflection point
is we're sort of still in right now is
the built you know continuing build a
foundation we got a new order management
system we're recruiting we boots new
office space all that sort of stuff
things to put infrastructure in place
that you can actually support growth and
I think we're getting to the point where
you know we're reaching that and that
inflection point and
the next one is coming up now which is
is the idea of sales milestones and and
actually and we have revenue but now
it's like how do we take this business
to the next level so I think I mean and
that's over the over the course of nine
months we've been through a million
different flex points or three major
ones that we've seen so many one thing
you'll see with the startup is that the
landscape shifts rapidly depending on
how you're moving yeah we petted
collection points every day no we have
we've had two major inflection points
the first one was we bootstrapped for a
long time because you know we wanted to
be ready when we go and when to go raise
some money and that was a bad idea
because and so the mount the inflection
point for us was when we actually raised
money there's something psychological
about actually having a salary and
having other people's money to spend on
the things need to spend versus your own
and so the moment we had money in the
bank and there was there were enough
zeroes in the checking account everybody
is for the one everyone felt a lot more
comfortable and our our productivity
skyrocketed and it was just
psychological because nothing else
really changed but you know our burn
rate didn't go up all that much but just
that there was a there's a procedure
perceptible perceivable shift in the
company's mentality so i would i would
urge you to raise money no matter what
it is raise some amount of money at the
beginning so that you feel like you have
a cushion the second inflection point
for us was first customer contact you
know we had we had designed this great
at it's great concept on paper we hadn't
yet programmed anything but we had all
these great power point slides that
showed everything we were going to do
and it was fantastic and then we started
showing it to customers and that was an
amazing experience because you think you
know everything you know nothing until
customers start telling you about their
real pains and and that feedback loop
you cannot create a great company
without it so our company just from a
product perspective took off once they
started taking customer meetings and we
start doing that on a very very regular
basis probably about three meetings a
week
but actually pay you Wilfred actually
get feedback because so you know it's
definitely I would say a work in
progress and it's probably the first
question I have to answer every time I
meet with an investor so I guess I'm
probably used to talking about it but um
you know it's been word of mouth for us
and we're starting to pay for it as well
but early on our first two customers
that came in april one was a GSB
classmate came up to me in the parking
lot of you know outside Littlefield
grabbed my hand and said I'm getting
married in August I don't know what to
do about bridesmaid dresses I heard
you're doing something do you have a
solution for me and I was like actually
um and it's sort of you know since since
we launched the website it's been a
combination of like word of mouth and
now playing around with cost per click
and you know we're in a lucky position
where with Facebook for example we can
chart the target women with status
engaged so there's a lot of interesting
stuff we can play around with their but
we're definitely focusing mostly on
online acquisition other than driving
word of mouth so our mottos a little
different it would be to be so you know
doing the consumer oriented position is
really make any sense so for us what
what's really worked for us is really
just getting through the network or
through relationships or any way we can
we try and get introductions to the most
senior executive we can at a company in
our target demo and that person will
generally give us 15-20 minutes because
what we're doing makes sense to them and
they need it and then that person will
route us to the appropriate person in
the organization and that's how not only
do we get feedback but we actually build
relationships and get leads for sales so
just from a consumer product sampling
event in consumer products or e-commerce
customer I conditions very tricking it's
something you need to be ready to
experiment and iterate
I think the way we did it when it was
launched tomatoes a lot of word-of-mouth
and through the course of may through
college January it was word about the PR
so we are in like daily candy oprah
magazine a few other places where people
saw us and they came to our site now
right now we're all more direct to
consumer and we're only available on our
website and so it's really at this point
you know now that we have money we're
turning on the faucet for marketing
spend and customer acquisitions a big
goal for 2011 but it's one where it's
you're not going to unlock if they want
you just need to experiment and figure
out you know what messaging works with
customers what's bringing to the site
what's making them convert and I mean
there's a lot of experimentation so you
know I know companies like bonobos even
they've been around for two or three
years they're doing great they're still
trying to figure it out so it's one of
those things were yet to keep and it's
one thing with startups in general you
iterate experiment all the time on
everything and that's a huge one
especially in consumer products a PR
firm we did yeah so we ended up we used
a PR firm starting in like july probably
of june or july negotiated a rate and
one thing you can do you'll find the
startup you can ago she ate a lot of
rates with with vendors as a start-up in
days they gave us half off and ended up
using them they you know one thing with
r-e-blu i do not how many of you know
the history were probably gonna view but
he used to be called rios logically
blimp beauty sleep drink and the idea
there was to get initial beachhead
customer with women women tended more
sleep issues ten people want to try and
advance we switched recent and natural
but the PR firm that we started working
with was very good with beauty and so we
were able to get placed in things like
Marie Claire Oprah Magazine things like
that and that was helpful but I'll tell
you if you didn't ecommerce business
customer acquisition is much more useful
when you get online PR like newsletters
and email so people can just click right
to your side
so my work experience is directly
relevant to what I do every day I you
know I spent four years in enterprise
sales and understanding how large
enterprises buy stuff is is a very
complex art and so having learned it you
know we don't we don't waste time trying
to figure that out and we've heard from
other people in the similar space that
they they're throwing themselves against
the wall trying to actually get any
traction inside a large organization and
we're not we're not dealing with that
because we know what we're doing in that
space that being said I think in
hindsight if I could go back and talk to
myself coming out undergrad I probably
would have tried to take the same job
but at an enterprise focus startup and
trying to learn or at least at some
point had taken a job working for a
start-up because there were things that
I worked at IBM for example there are
things that I learned at IBM or that I
was used to at IBM that just don't apply
when you're an early stage startup that
you know we're now learning the hard way
I'll give you two thoughts on that one
is just on my day-to-day and what I'm
able to do I'd rebloom I mean I think I
did consulting project I think it was
really valuable training just in terms
of thinking about business judgment
thinking about how to deal with
different different parties how to build
a team out of build a culture so all
that stuff is very valuable and that
plus stuff either into the GSB I will
tell you when i was when i was talking
to consumer product companies and doing
recruiting coming out of the GSP no one
cared about the fact that i was in it
was a pain i didn't place called british
partners in both decent places like
everyone cared about bonobos because I
was much more applicable just there's a
start-up and that's so in hindsight I
don't know what the right answers for me
and hindsight I mean I'm very happy with
the training I got but potentially
having more had I known earlier I want
to do consumer products or startups
having more of that in my resume would
have been more helpful but I mean I
think it sort of depends on how sure you
are in terms of where you want to go
yeah
this is an issue that is very near and
dear to my heart as a can attest
emerging from miami florida and I allows
in school all I want to do is go back
there and start my company there
regardless of what city are in the one
thing that I found was that different
cities have a network effect if you want
to start a technology company and you
don't do it here it's going to be very
very difficult the talents here the
money's here heck half the customers
will even really talk to a start-up to
work with are here if you're in consumer
tech you know the the people who are
most comfortable adopting a new
technology are also here and so you know
it's very difficult to start something
outside of a city where the it's not
their focus I mean the same goes through
free no la if you want to media probably
shipping down there I want to do finance
York's good place so those competitive
advantages feed into individual cities
it's needed it as I tried to move to
Miami I started to run into in a very
very real way and so I had to actually
decide to stay here because of all this
advantages and he hates it here I love
it here no I do i do I live in Pacific
live on the beach it's fantastic so I
get a little slice of Miami it's a
little colder though well it's nice no I
do quite love it here yeah I probably
have a slightly different perspective I
think weddington way probably is a bit
more flexible in terms of location we
could be in New York for example where
the fashion industry is or there are
different places we could be I think the
choice to be in san francisco and the
reason i guess we decided that San
Francisco really makes sense for us part
of it is I was here at the GSB for two
years and the entire network I built a
ramp while I was building this business
is in the valley um any question that I
have is a coffee away and that makes
things a lot easier um you know as we
have in Bound interest from investors I
can you know grab a coffee here and
there with investors who are interested
in weddington way and get to know them
and build a relationship with them
before I'm raising my next round of
financing so that just makes sort of
everything a lot more
like natural I an easier for us on that
front um and then in terms of talent
recruitment I do think it's valuable
being in a location where there are a
lot of people who are interested in
working at startups and understand the
trade-offs between cash and equity and
it's just it's a part of the lifeblood
here that necessarily the case in other
places we have another 2,000 grad 2010
gret camped out in our office he was
starting a company he's very
deliberately moving back to Pittsburgh
but he's getting this company I've been
going and funded here and hoping to port
it back to Pittsburgh so hopefully don't
do it but i'll give you a completely
different perspective I chose my
location had nothing to do with
professional stuff it was more just like
I prior than GSB I taken the best
opportunity and I was in Boston and New
York for a while and I'd literally I
think that GSP was very good at getting
me to think about what was going to make
me happy and content and I'm a very
instinctive in person and my instinct
was pointing me toward San Francisco
strong enough to the point where I
turned down three offers in New York and
sign the lease in San Francisco that a
job the same week and that was to accept
her graduation so I mean for me it was
just like this felt like the right city
and I figured everything else will fall
into place I mean I think all this up
that these guys said was true and it's
turned out to be great but it was much
more this instinct driven yeah how did
you get in track for those first cold
call to you did either investor for the
companies that he promised
did you talk to people to just cut up
build power point presentations like
actual video so I just did what I did
for four and a half years I don't do
cold calls I I deliberately try and get
someone introduce me to somebody else
because it changes everything you do it
that way but there were times when we
had to do a cold call in fact one of our
one of the customers that we work with
on a regular basis I called emailed the
CIO a fortune 100 company and he
responded and we had a meeting that was
very um that was very tricky the first
line wasn't with GSB grad and that helps
a lot they will take a meeting so that's
how I start the meetings and that's how
I get the meetings if you will I try and
work through someone and that's the most
effective ways we can do it linkedin is
a fantastic way to get go about that so
you can see who knows in somebody else
and then if it really comes down to a
cold email you know you really want to
just make yourself seem credible in the
first line and be really clear with them
exactly what you want and if you're
trying to get feedback you should be
very clear that you are just trying to
get feedback and not trying to sell them
a product or trying to sell them a
product be clearing that because people
if you're kind of vague they and they
don't want to deal with it in terms of
the meeting I i always have powerpoints
all I meetings are on webex and you know
I came a power points is clean and it's
simple as humanly possible but at least
for us what we're doing is sufficiently
complex where I need a diagram to just
convey the concepts fast enough we can
get a lot of time in terms of time I
limit everything to 20 minutes 20 min of
meetings anything past that they start
getting antsy they may not take the
meeting and I tell them up front of the
email and I tell them up front them in
the actual meaning that it's going to be
20 minutes so that everybody is kind of
cool and then I just have really clear
idea of what I want out of the meeting
what are the question what are the three
questions I need answered if it's
feedback where the three feedback
questions if it's i'm trying to sell
them on being our partner or paying us
for something
there are three questions that I wanted
to get answered in that direction and
try and get those answered and
everything else is gravy in the meeting
but that's all angles well I mean two
things I would say one is I don't
getting started I don't think you need
to deal with cold calls that you should
have strong that network from the GSB
and your friends hair to get at least
more meetings and more mint-rose and
with everyone you talk to they're going
to realize they like you they like idea
whatever and they have people they can
refer you to and then you have this nice
path of going down just warm referrals I
think Cole calls are pretty difficult in
general and nothing just echo something
Alex said one thing someone told me
before fundraising which became very
true was if you want money ask for
advice if you want advice ask for money
because people you know they will add
they're happy to give you feedback if
they're really interested then they
might follow up but the second you come
to someone saying I'm raising money I'm
sure you want to invest people just kind
of turn away no go ahead i just i come i
guess from a slightly different
perspective because i did mention the
cold call thing i actually initially had
tried to use my network in the fashion
industry to get to the brands that i
wanted to meet with and it was just
taking too long because i was in
ready-to-wear and the wedding industry
is a little bit different so ultimately
I just decided this is taking too long
i'm just going to call them and it's
sort of knowing your audience so i
definitely didn't mention that i'm a
business school student at Stanford I'm
a former buyer from bloomingdales
starting this awesome company so it was
just really at the end of the day and
then it's like when you're in that
situation like at least for that's a
true jew I mean you have to like act
larger than life and you have to make
them think that you know this is like
the train that's like passing them by
and they gotta jump on and we sort of I
guess my tactic which can be a bit
personal but so odd should be like
that's a great point so when I throw one
F when I was throwing the GS I'm a GSB
grad in the first line that was to get
feedback right because when you present
yourself as your news your new grad
you're young you're wet behind the ears
are trying to get feedback people open
up and they'll tell you they'll give you
feedback they'll give you all the advice
in the world you can get a lot of data
when you are actually trying to get a
business relationship off the ground and
you really
meet with them to actually try and build
something our first line is not that our
first line is actually talk about our
open source project and how successful
that's going so we were legitimate you
know they know we're credible we have a
community behind us we know we're
talking about that's on ask you a
question cuz I think one of the most
critical skills and entrepreneur can
have is in sales and you obviously had
some great training in an organization
has some of the best sales training what
recommendations you have for people who
don't have four years in IBM and don't
have that sales training ok how can they
figure out how two semanas it as a
entrepreneur you're constantly so yeah
so I'll give you two things that I think
are our kind of my up there's a loop
I'll try and keep it quick um songs we
don't tie his hands easy yeah there's a
few things the first is you need to
understand how your customers by your
customers go through a buying process
and if you are not sensitive to their
buying process you use trying to close a
deal not only you're not going to close
a deal you're going to piss them off and
they're not going to talk you ever again
and so what that means is your customers
go through a very simple buying process
which is okay well what do I really need
right what am I trying to accomplish
what are my initiatives etc and if you
get to talk them at that point when
they're trying to figure out what
exactly it is that they're trying to buy
or you can help build a vision around
what they actually need based on the
future sets that you've built the second
step in the process is once they kind of
know what they need then it's not okay
well what am I opposite what are the
things I can what are the different
products i can buy or the solutions i
can implement and that's when you
traditionally do the pitching and then
once you go through that process then
after they've seen everything and
they've figured out if you are something
that does make sense for what they need
then you go into closing mode what
everybody talks about is always be
closing that that's the dumbest thing on
the planet i hate networks because
customers don't react well to that and
then once you're in club but when you
once you are in close mode be really
clear with your customer that you are in
close mode and try and close the deal
but i could probably go on for an hour
and how you actually do that but it's
you know when your startup it's not that
complicated you say hey listen can we
close this when can you buy what do you
need to make the purchase and that's
enough early on the next thing is be
brutal with your customers or at least
your customer management in that listen
if your customers too small or your
customer doesn't have budget for your
customers planning on buying it in like
18 months stop talking about um just
because it's this great brand doesn't
mean you should waste all this time
trying to get them to close with you if
they don't budget them time frame you're
talking about first and they don't
really have a need you you're too busy
so once you realize that someone doesn't
have budget authority needs in time time
frame move on to the next deal otherwise
you're just going to you're going to
waste your time I think the last thing
is start at the top if you're if you're
selling to an organization start as high
as you possibly can start from the
organization I think four rookies and
sales it is too easy to convince
yourself that oh I can get a meeting
with this guy's the bottom so I'm just
going to do that because the senior
person won't want to talk to me and you
start talking to that person what
happens in our organization is that that
low level person might give you a lot of
great feedback but they will generally
believed that they are the authority on
the purchase and they generally aren't
and once you build a relationship with
them they might feel that they should be
owning the relationship with you and if
you try and get a meeting with someone
in a different department or higher than
them they might feel like you're going
over their head so you might have a
political issue on your hands which
becomes a really big problem in your
deal stalls now you can't talk to anyone
else to try and save the deal and so
deals can drag on in this case the worst
dictionary is you might lose a deal and
never even know you lost it cuz your
talk of the wrong person if you need at
the top that person is going to route
you to the right person the moment he
knows what you're selling like oh this
is really interesting I want to learn
more about it Bob's the guide is in
charge of us and you meet with Bob and
you did it in one meeting and now
because Bob's we gonna write you down
one of his guys and might write down one
of his guys you might end up at the
bottom but now because you've built a
relationship with everybody on the way
down if the deal stalls you can work
your way back up and the last thing is
the most important thing the salesperson
can do is not be social it's not be like
a fun person to hang out with it's not
even having a good pitch like all that
stuff's pretty commodity
everyone knows that the most important
thing is being able to answer customer
objection when a customer says oh I
don't want your product is too expensive
you can't just go okay customers tell
you all the reasons they won't buy your
product what they're really doing is
they're testing their understanding of
what you're selling and it whether or
not they need it so when they say what's
too expensive oh it's tobago it's too
slow whatever you want to flesh that out
you want to understand where they're
coming from why do you say it's too
expensive well maybe it's because they
don't have budget means because they're
caring to a different product maybe it's
because they're comparing is completely
irrelevant you want to understand that
stuff so that then you can formulate a
response be like well I understand these
things too expensive calm but if you
consider the cost of building it
yourself which is what your alternative
really is this is actually at the price
you know and so you can you can you can
respond to a lot of customer objections
and if you do that your sales workers
I'm by the way Harvard has a study that
actually prove that that was the most
effective thing for successful so sweet
so there's your sales class I can start
we had a really big obstacle we we hit
we hit a bit of a roadblock was about
five months ago we got we we were
getting a lot of really high quality
feedback we were meeting with all our
target customers and we were just
getting really high quality feedback and
based on that feedback we realized that
the product we were planning on building
and taken to market had a had a business
model flaw to it and and we agonized on
what we're going to do right because we
we saw this is this is not going to work
the way it's currently architect and the
way we're gonna have to go to market so
we had to pivot the product in in the
business school classes they'll talk
about how companies pivot and they'll
say that you know all this feedback you
should pivot if you realize that the
market insight the tell hindsight on how
you pivot and you see these companies a
pivoted it all worked out beautifully
when you are pivoting he is terrifying
it is it is the most difficult
even gone through we weren't even sure
we can survive the pivot because
attached to that was when we raised
money we were we were optimistic we
raise money and so we raised money based
on the fact that I here's how things
will play out and when you pivot you
essentially you take a few steps back
and they were good steps have to be
taken but suddenly you know your
financing isn't really line up with the
road up anymore so now you know now
you're like well how do we actually
finance ourselves through the process we
now know we have to go through all over
again with the new product it was very
very difficult so my only advice is
don't be scared to pivot because you're
going to have to if you actually have a
problem with your business with your
business model and when you are raising
your initial setup of your initial round
of capital make sure you're raising
enough to survive a pivot or two because
chances are you will go through one I
mean there's a lot of obstacles we face
a I think of a specific one that might
be helpful the question mean one thing
is when we were fundraising we received
a term sheet from well-known seed fund
in the area that was pretty onerous in
terms of just a lot of terms that we
would never want to sign and so as an
obstacle it was kind of like well here's
here's the term stairs fundraising but
science them we don't feel good about vs
well we have some cash the bank why
don't we keep fundraising and there's a
risk of losing this this big round and I
think that's where I go back to one of
the things I think I've found it's been
the most important is having your values
in line and so like John and I talked
about it extensively and you know we got
this point we like you know what we
don't want to sign something we feel
uncomfortable with and so we'd rather
you know we've as long as underlined the
underlying confidences are that we have
a product that'll work and we have a
business that we can build we don't want
to go forward with the term sheet that
that didn't make sense for us and so we
actually decided not to sign it which is
a big obvious going to be decision and
we were comfortable with going out with
their own term sheet and raising glass
or whatever another terms you happen to
come in work that great but I mean that
was one where I just think there's any
obstacles of tests on you
values and so as long as you know you
and cody co-founder you're important /
online and you're building a culture
where people are sort of thinking along
the same core values I think that's
really important in terms of obstacles
you know challenges we face every day I
think one of the biggest ones is is just
trying to juggle a million things
there's there's no end there's no end in
terms of things to do and so one thing
that I found very helpful recently which
goes back to the G speed I'd never take
a classic tell Peterson but a classmate
of mine did and and tell me about this
two-by-two that he uses in terms of
trying to prioritize things where on one
axis is not important important and on
the top layer it's not urgent urgent and
so I've been you have a whiteboard over
my desk where now I have that and like
urgent and important I'm going to take
care of today all the other stuff can
wait and that's that's been helped
that's helped us get through only one of
the biggest challenges which is just the
fact that two people trying to a million
things not enjoy that for me we share an
office and it was eight or 830 on a
Wednesday night and he dragged me out of
here is after drawing me that got two by
two um I guess so you know it's a hard
question to answer I guess because we
are still a very early stage so I think
there are you know lots of challenges um
I don't know what the biggest one is you
know one thing that we're going through
right now is transitioning from super
lean bootstrap mode to spending to grow
and just getting comfortable with
growing our team increasing our burn and
that's just something you know a part of
it is just that's where having a team
composed of people who have like faith
in the business and really are
passionate about the opportunity and
what we're building bringing in
contractors everyone we work with is
really like passionate about the
opportunity and that's a really
important piece of you know I guess just
spending into into growth for us I think
um because it's
you know you're constantly taking leaps
of faith and you know then I I mean we
have we have lots of little challenges
we went to New York at the end of
January to it was to meet with members
of the media who would reached out to us
who were interested in covering
weddington way to meet with suppliers
and you know we had while we were there
we had one of the meetings we were most
excited about with someone really senior
at a magazine like they canceled on us
last minute and it's just like you know
that stuff that happens all the time and
you have to deal with it and they ended
up making an introduction to up for us
to an editor in LA he's actually the
edit or we should be talking to anyway
and so it was like trying to like you
know put everything in perspective and
realize what would the goal of that
meeting have been and it would have been
an introduction to that editor so maybe
we just saved ourselves an hour while in
New York and we can do something else at
that time and focus on the fact that we
know this other contact so it's just I
mean they're always there are big and
little things and it's just a matter of
like continuing to like push forward and
just and you have to really believe in
what you're doing to whatever the
obstacle is to to keep pushing forward
otherwise you won't be able to get up in
the morning
and it's recurrently driving and I'm
currently dudes dropping yeah I still AM
um so equity is really important um it's
a really important thing I mean you know
something that like we've talked a lot
about is that you have to be smart with
equity and who you give it to but
generous when you find the right people
because you want the people joining you
to be not employees but owners of the
company with you so that's been i would
say number one and that's uh you know
other than that it's you know figuring
out i mean we have conversations a jay
was talking about like negotiating with
PR firms I mean but we're in the process
of hiring a PR firm right now with
contractors we've employed you know we
sort of always talk to them it's very
important for us that the people who
work for us make sure that they're being
compensated appropriately um so just
having a really open conversation with
everyone we work with about what we can
and cannot afford in making sure that
we're partnering with people who are
excited about what we're doing and sort
of an x in and really you know we come
to understandings we don't want people
to be doing work for us where they feel
like we're sort of just completely under
compensating them because you're not
going to get the best out of them so
really just having open communication
with people you employ and making sure
they're sort of on board with what
you're doing nice
so well we have we have a law firm that
we use in the valley called Wilson
Sonsini which does a lot of financing
and so when John was starting the
company we used in foreign corporation
sort of documents need to have up front
and basically they agreed to defer to
expect differences that we raced around
and I think that's sort of standard for
those law firms that are pretty
expensive and we tend to use them only
one we need to because hourly rates are
pretty high but they were very useful
from incorporation for trademark stuff
for financing all that sort of stuff now
that we have money and now that we're
looking at at milestones to kind of take
it to the next level of growth we're
also exploring legal options from a
consumer product standpoint we sell an
adjustable there are certain issues that
potentially come up in terms of terms
and conditions claims you make all that
sort of stuff and so we're at the early
stages of that and we haven't you know I
think the one thing we've learned is
having a good having a good lawyer is
very helpful especially getting a lot of
documents on we had one letter from
another company that was you know claim
that that we had taken a trademark which
was wrong but we had a very strong
lawyer that sent them a letter that
basically shut them up and you know a
lot of work our planes that we wouldn't
be able to do so i think there's lot of
value there and i think where we are i
don't know what's a going forward but
it's like we're trying to leverage much
advice as we can i don't think we'll
have anyone on retainer per se but just
haven't good contact to be helpful
I did not know did not used to turn at
all I mean that was very much like I I
liked him a lot we got along he gave me
an offer that I mean to the Alana's
point he gave me an offer where I was
excited to join the team and he was
excited to have me and that was try
didn't see anything to please a lawyer
if I can just quit coming on that so one
of our advisors of gave us great advice
on on seeking seeking legal advice then
we took to heart and I now see the
wisdom in that advice first advice was
wait as long as humanly possible before
you engage board as an early stage
startup until you actually have any kind
of contract that you sign don't engage
with a lawyer because it's an expense
and and it's a distraction as well like
you will spend time with the lawyer and
even if it's just three hours that's
three hours you should be spending
making sure you actually have a company
because incorporating something that's
never going to sell anything is
irrelevant so we waited as long as we
possibly could until we were actually
about to start talking to a customer and
I start giving some work for them that
we actually started incorporating three
get the legal protection such really
what it's there for there to give you
legal protection the second thing is um
you know pick the best partner you can
get at the law firm and that will also
be by referral if you just call up
Wilson Sonsini or just call of fenwick
and west and try and get you know
somebody to help you you might not get
the best person work your network to try
and get the best partner you can because
they're going to give you advice when
you need it specifically around
fundraising because they see more deals
and venture capitalists see so and if
they ask for equity it's a small amount
of equity it is a drop in the bucket you
know compared to the alleged gonna go
from these guys so I guess I mean I'll
just answer that quickly I guess I'm
sort of probably in line with what Alex
said maybe slightly counter so the
waiting as long as you can I guess maybe
I i paid for like our first sort of
orders on my personal credit card to our
suppliers and that was the point at
which i realized i should probably be
incorporating um so that might have been
waiting as
as possible but on the other hand I
would say just on the flip side if
you're looking to build something big
you want to make sure you're doing it
right so for me like my lawyers know
where I stand and I'm not going to be
talking to them on the phone two hours a
week but when it's important I'm going
to involve them and if it costs a little
extra fine you know just because I'm
trying to build something and don't want
to screw it up and Biggs is for a reason
so I think there's like a balancing act
there of making sure you're being smart
about building something scalable yes so
in terms of fundraising so we didn't use
them to actually meet investors and get
to that point but once we had a term
sheet in place we used we help them we
use them in terms of like our stock
purchase agreement all the agreements
that we use to close but then the lead
investor also had a lawyer too so that
was kind of balance that out
good I took out a loan in May I hadn't
borrowed against a hundred percent of my
tuition so I'm you know I've been living
off of the student loan at three percent
which is pretty cheap financing I did
the same thing I mean I newest imma
start a company out of school so I
borrowed all signals we can get even I
didn't eat them and kept all my cash I i
didn't i didn't pay for any school out
of my savings all three percent loans
which is free money and also my wife
works which really really really it's my
favorite quotes is from Josh greenberg
somebody asked him this question one
time he says when your statuses look
around this is for me I look for the
cutest girl I could possibly find made
sure she had earning potential in
Meritor have to know Josh she's
hysterical she does she that depends on
the business say that I've raised three
hundred K so far my commitments the week
of graduation were thirty play from
classmates so built the website with
twelve thousand dollars bootstrap can
meet a bunch of different things right
if you actually have money to do it you
don't have to give out a converted one
out or razor friends and family around
but a lot of people just try and raise
what they need right away just to get
the foundation of plays i know'd John
raised a couple hundred K in friends and
family and was very cost-conscious in
terms of you know getting to a product
launch and and then
we obviously raised more but second I
took them a long way we didn't pay
ourselves for four months and then
raised a few min about Miller's I guess
we have 10 minutes left impart your
wisdom on the students here what advice
you would have for them maybe even glean
from the good advice that you've got
what has resonated with you that you
want to pass on to this next generation
um I guess I started spooked to it a
little bit um but I think the best
advice I could give is use your time at
the GSB to take as many risks as
possible um even I was thinking about
when Alex was answering the sales
question I mean if you don't have sales
like a lot of it is part of it as
strategy and part of it is gusto and
just use the time you know I did in my
second year I did I gave a talk you know
as part of top 10 for our class and it's
so it's not just in business but like
taking personal risk like push yourself
outside your comfort zone get
comfortable with that whether you end up
doing a start-up or working at a large
enterprise like the sort of being
comfortable sort of pushing yourself
outside your comfort zone taking risk
it's something you have the luxury of
like two years at school to do in all
sorts of different ways I mean I I'd
have a bunch of things I could say that
we're helpful to me I probably said a
few of them I mean one find some of the
underlying values to work within its
super critical to from for the GSB first
years especially for anybody regardless
where you wanna go I say take mg and
take touchy-feely for people who wanted
to start ups 2-3 56 and another thing
that from an academic standpoint i take
aligning startups with their markets
with rackleff and Bartlett or barnett
sorry and forceps the epiphany was one
of the books that they had us read and
that's one of the best books I've ever
read on entrepreneurship and building a
business in the right way using customer
development we've heard those questions
around obstacles and inflection points
and I think you have to realize it it's
not like a business school case we look
back
obvious obstacles obvious inflection
points mean every single day we've all
set up at every single day there's some
new challenges some new inflection
points on your obstacle and just like
realize that if you believe in your
product you believe in your company you
know you'll get over those various
roadblocks you just got to keep moving
forward and then two piece of advice I
got that I thought were extremely
helpful for me I was making decisions
one thing is that all great
entrepreneurs one thing they do is they
mitigate risk whether it's you know
business decisions they make or whatever
and I think if you think about this in
terms of your own career one a great way
to mitigate risk is go to the GSB and so
like I think everyone here is in a good
position to start a company because
you've already know if it doesn't work
so what you have Jesus be and whatever
else did before to fall back on and for
me that was a huge deal i actually don't
feel that much stress even though we
have so you know a long way to go to
make anything happen and then the final
thing is the idea of just doing it it's
so cliche but the reality is it's like
one thing I found is that you're so much
more ready for this than you think you
are and I had enough excuses you know I
was thinking about raising a search
funnest thing we didn't start of stuff
talking people for my private equity
firm those at talking other people like
well why don't I try and do this for a
couple years you know one of the offers
I turned out of New York was a big
company that was ready to go you know
get sold to it just actually got sold a
amazon shortly after I let it go but I
mean I think you know my idea there was
I go there I get more credibility and
then I'd spin off with someone to start
something that the reality was you know
ready to do it now why not just do it I
think that's nine every cent of it of
getting there so that's my breakfast
yeah if your first year student and you
think you will at some point want to
start a remotely tech-oriented company
you have to take the ante rackleff
Barnett class if you don't you are
throwing away or India you play might
have to round zero that one yeah you
have to run 0 that one yeah so that is
the best class and the most applicable
class I took related to tech and if you
can't get into it or you decide to not
take my advice make sure you get the
reading list and read all the books
forceps to the epiphany is the first
book they read there's another one
called cost crossing the chasm there's
another one called innovator solution
which is also as appearing a book called
innovators dilemma with both our
Goodreads so if you can't take a class
read the books if you do take the class
and if you do not go to lunch with a
near a cliff twice a week like he offers
you are also wasting your money the GSK
so strong words I also let go touchy
feely touchy feely Zach Liz is a thing
we use every single day because it is
hard to start a company and those skills
I use every single day when my partner
and I are having problems for those few
her alums that is available now through
life one learning as well yeah so
fantastic class if also I i will say if
you do have a tech vent I love you but I
would not take 56 I do not recommend it
it is the process you go through does
not lend itself properly to the process
you will have to go through for a new
tech new tech concept it's a to region
and to linear of a process and that's
just not how tech companies are started
it is used it has a change whenever you
hang up did you do to 73 over the
engineering school anybody know if any
we did FL Fenech there yeah so i need
you i didn't 36 twice so i I really
don't recommend it and if you're a
second year or you will eventually be
second year or you're just not a GSB
student one advice that was given to me
that I definitely appreciate when I was
a student and now I appreciate it you
don't have to start a company the moment
you graduate right there's this pressure
when you here at Stanford especially
here at Stanford that you have to start
a company of course because you know
there's Facebook down the street and
your friend just launched a social
networking company that's you know being
valued at like nine billion dollars you
know over like two weeks and so you have
to do the same thing you don't and if
you give yourself the pressure that you
have to start a company you will make
bad decisions and you will take a
concept that maybe isn't good market
maybe it's not you know maybe super
competitive so you don't give yourself
that pressure and now if you do have a
concept that you do want to start out of
school you will never be more ready than
you are today the concept of let me go
work for a start-up up you just put
because I'm going to learn
that I need to know no trust me you will
learn enough on the job and if it really
is something that you need to know and
you don't know you can hire someone so
there's no need to wait if you do have
something that's really compelling and
the last thing is your idea your idea
sucks right except it's not a secret if
you go talk to people they're not going
to steal your idea and go public
tomorrow it's it's not going to happen
so don't keep it a secret because I
promise you whatever I knew you have
right now it's wrong it is it is
completely wrong and you're not going to
know it until you actually start sharing
with people so this whole stealth
concept totally great absolutely agree
only because there's two minutes left
and I have a chance to kind of lab in a
couple piece of pizzas of advice and I
totally echo a lot of what these guys
say but I mean if you're a student you
have a great opportunity become an
expert in something and these guys
alluded to it I mean alex is right
people will tell you things they
shouldn't be telling you when you're a
student I mean absolutely positively
leverage the hell out of that and be
calling people in becoming an expert in
something and a Jay alluded to your
night kind of putting a stake in the
ground in terms of words interests are
people do a much better job responding
to a specific request than 2 i'm really
trying to find a cool company to work
with or start that if you start with
something you're going to iterate your
way to where it is you want to be so
even if it's an artificial constraint
and you can probably do too artificial
constraints simultaneously but there's a
lot of value in really having something
specific for folks to respond to it in
alex commented you don't need to start a
business right out of school anecdotally
the larger number of our alums who
started businesses have done so two to
three years out frequently its
particular if you're coming from and
consulting our investment banking
background you haven't been in industry
haven't seen where there's a really big
need to find that big market that
growing market that alex talks about so
if you get out an institute you will
find that bigger market so there's
certainly an argument for waiting a
couple years and there's a good argument
for doing it earlier rather than later
and one another thing I'll just all
about to you Corey Ford's in the other
room
kind of bummed his at the same time as
mine but he's launched this really cool
program called the runway project part
of innovation endeavors and I think he's
going to come back spring quarter but if
those of you are thinking about wanting
to do something entrepreneurial but
aren't too sure what I encourage you to
look into the runway project they're
trying to use this project shed model of
putting smart people in a room to find
that big market to find that big idea
and then develop the idea and launch it
so I mean it's an answer I get to it
would have the so many students are in
my office saying I want to start
something but I don't know what Corey
Ford it's called the runway project part
of innovation endeavors which is funded
by Eric Schmidt and of course well
they're not taping his workshop but you
can take a look at his website he just
launched the first class in February's
been a lot to another one in august but
applications are due i think by april
but hopefully he'll be coming back
spring quarter to talk so and even super
well thank you thank you for chatting
with my friends